gang the state trashy tour is coming to
a city near you stand up comedy plus
we've played the Leo IG with the crowd
shows are selling out and you can get
your tickets at rugarbage.com see you
there
[Music]
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage it's that little
shall we sit down with your favorite
comedians and we find that it's great to
be classy yes you're just a big old
piece of trash I'm your host Saint
Charlie coming at you on a beautiful day
we're out back here with Toadies in the
new edition she's in the kitchen
whipping up a hot meal for the boys
meatloaf sandwiches tonight okay what a
cold glass of milk okay she's a whiz in
that kitchen sure whether it's that of
the meth she does a really good job I
shout out the Blue Magic Mike co-host is
coming at you from across the table the
body surfing King a Wildwood New Jersey
let's go back to claim the crown KJ
Kevin James Ryan what up gang thanks for
tuning in pal as always please make sure
your rate if you subscribe on iTunes
full video available YouTube as you know
those numbers are
[__] then obviously the greatest
website of all time well over 10 000
subscribers over there patreon.com are
you garbage gang we're closing in on the
Ireland trip we're [__] cranking out
a bajillion hours of content over there
pity Old Country back to the old country
Cody's taking the boys back home I might
shed a tear over there and I'll tell you
that yeah yeah
okay this guy's getting real sentimental
at the top of the show get a hooker to
kick me in the nuts
that's [__] begged me uh then
obviously the second greatest website of
all time uh www.ru garbage.com gang you
go over there you get every Ticket
available for the live shows on a stay
trashy Thor for the fall and winter
those tickets are moving gang and
t-shirts and t-shirts Zippo style
lighters better believe it they work
that's in parentheses but legally they
sent us a season this is wearing a lot
of call them Zippos anymore Zippo style
lighters but get tickets to the door
gang it's a good time come out and see
us gang we love you and have a nice
quick shout out to our producer Rick
short and here the magic man makes us
all look good works the ones and twos
crosses the t's and dots the eyes give
it up a T-bone mcgruffins it's Toby
McMullen everybody what up boys Thomas
what up I cannot wait to go to Ireland
dude get get Foley in one of those
little Newsies caps a jacket with an
elbow patch he's crying he's never seen
so many potatoes it'll be amazing you're
Scotch yes sir rough you up when you're
over there [__] have you in a
headlock the whole time yeah noogies
this guy of us if you think I'm not
making you wear a kilt over there you're
nuts yeah that's happening with that big
old wee-wee hanging out the bottom I may
still have one [__] T-Bone hanging
really why did you have one to begin
with my folks love that [__] my dad has
one my brother I see Dr D rolling around
one of those yeah or a free ball in it
he's real real Tootsie weekend his phds
from the University of Aberdeen Scotland
ah yes sir he loves the regalia dude he
puts out he's got the long scarf the big
robe The Kilt with his balls out big old
beans for breakfast oh my God the Pete
um I want to go in the fall
if we can I want it to be cold over
there I want to do the gear do the
[__] the wool sweater and the cabbie
basketball shorts
pair of flip-flops pair of Celtic shorts
sure yeah I want to go in I don't know
we got to see when we're gonna hit the
goal and then that you know we then have
to carve out time to get over that that
ain't no [__] hop skill that ain't
Wildwood New Jersey I want those Customs
involved there's flights there's
layovers I want cold I want the rain and
the sheep and the green grass it rains
almost every day
Dublin right and that I think the plan
is to hit every major uh major city can
we stay in a country a little bit yeah
of course nice maybe rent like a little
Farmhouse I don't know I could do some
writing
get my Memoirs in order write a couple
of goodies
up there cooking dinner
yeah yeah
I'd be I haven't really thought about
that it kind of hit me uh they were
closing in on I mean we're like a
thousand or you know not that far away
from for from hitting the gold yeah I
mean that was always something we know
we never went when I was a kid either
that way I went over drinking with this
is bigger than my buddy Disney from you
know sentimentally for me oh yeah and my
uncle used to always tease me he'd be
like when I was a kid like you're gonna
go back and I'm like go back where
everybody yeah for the old country I
hate that because they're not from there
but they went yeah but they went because
busting my balls take it easy
yeah okay oh man oh he's in his bag he
was just Googling psychiatrists
uh no but I mean my family does it too
it's a thing of like it's so distant of
who came over sure maybe like back to
the old country like you have some sort
of real connection to it I know when my
great great I think great great great
grandfather came over William Foley was
the first one to come over he came over
and fought in the Spanish American war
and we didn't want him back
you can stay there you know thank God
he's gone yeah when was the
Spanish-American work can you give me a
goog on that I want to say it was 1830
something like that that's when he came
over uh
1898 97
19.
it was the millennial Back to the Future
it just come out uh oh did a bunch of
these little horses singing um Bob
but I don't get that because wait hold
on when was it 1898 yeah that's when he
came over
he was the first I don't know if I don't
know if his wife was already here or not
they settled in Germantown uh in
Wilkes-Barre it was a neighborhood sure
in uh in Wilkes-Barre yeah even the
Irish didn't want them had to go to
[__] Germantown there's always a
German Town everywhere yeah it was named
that's where all the Germans lived I
wonder why they lived over there it's
[__] dead when he came over here you
gotta stick together nobody talked the
language he got you a job no I wanna I
wanna know why my Irish family moved in
there because he's a [__] turncoat
probably that's why he's probably
trading giving secrets away on how to
make mashed potatoes or something I
heard about the Schnitzel yeah [__]
family full of rats all you like it's a
good good sauerkraut
um but yeah my family does we don't have
a huge that huge connection like back to
the old country but like everybody that
has made the play we don't but we do you
know I know I know you know how we are
you yeah you yeah the old country means
like your nana went there I worked I
worked at Irish such a [__] horse
thieves I worked at an Irish bar when I
first moved up here any any of the Irish
guys that came over hated my guts yeah
they've yeah they couldn't stand me you
know I'm giving them the wrong change
back and stuff at the bar you're all
perked up in a Bend again
I was a huge [__] and they were right
but we have an effect like um I always
bought the colada Rings my mom has a
collateral I mean I get the Irish I I to
me it's a you know from a very
irish-american family that to have
irish-american culture is different than
Irish culture I would argue same as
Italian-American culture is way
different the Italians hate the Italian
Americans [__] pests do not they [__]
it I seen The Sopranos they [__] hate
those those Guinea bass but an
irish-american culture is
yeah irish-american culture is what were
you was what you know yeah is what we
know 100 yeah yeah yeah we're all about
it supposed to pull up in a green and
white cat in the hat Dr Seuss hat on
Kiss Me I'm Irish shirt put Shamrock
sunglasses God get the [__] beat out of
me
yeah
hey man can you heat this beer up a
little more this is great got nothing
cold back there what are you doing
uh yeah ah good stuff uh I got something
I wanted to get uh what do you got I get
kicked off this Fam Family episode get
the get the cruise take on here because
this has been uh
about you know uh at the moment I'm
carless I got no wheels got no way to
get around
um I was going down to visit my ma uh
last week and I had uh I couldn't get a
[__] Rental Car in New York City
uh-huh I had no wheels to get anywhere
uh which has been a long time I've had a
car for past you know handful of years
in the city not being able to maneuver
or get to where you want to go is is you
know it's a rude awakening helpless
helpless out here with my dick in my
hand I mean you can always rent one you
could hop to train but if [__] went down
you're in trouble I'm in trouble I died
[__] throw my pair of rollerblades
and get right over that gwb that's true
but uh unless they blow it then you're
[__] I don't [__] care I'm going to
get a slice from the [__] pizza place
relax a little bit man if they're my
hands on a flatbread if they're blowing
the bridges I would have the most epic
relapse dude
before the last piece of concrete hit
that water I'd have a Miller High Life
two cuties and a tall boy that ain't
some [__] they tell you on the news
beforehand no you're like what are those
two f-16s just come over Bing Bing [__]
something happened I don't know where
they did that they did it in I Am Legend
I think it was and they blew to Bridges
jammed up I'm sitting here by myself
doing the [__] anybody out there is
there anybody I'll be at Aunt tutty's
house every day from sun up to sundown
man because you know monsters get you
yeah you jammed up so I tried to rent a
car but I couldn't get my hands on
anything in New York anything relatively
close to me isn't it funny I'd be having
to go to the I'm not going to the
airport to rent a car no that's that's
bad I'm not going to the airport unless
I'm flying it's funny The Surge times on
that [__] like there's a lot of times in
New York where you can't get a hotel
room yeah everything's sold out yeah
it's like a Wednesday everything's sold
out well I think because in New York now
it was the weekend everybody who lives
in New York doesn't have a car they rent
a car to go to the lot they go to the
island they go visit their parents what
happened to Zipcar are they tank no I
think they're still banging yeah uh I
just don't have a count then you gotta
set up the account I was looking at Toro
which is the dirt bag [__] car rental
program which I belong to you and your
girl riding a rebel scooter
which for a long time the only way I
could get a car Harry and Lloyd the only
time I could get a car was from Toro
which is remember the Airbnb for your
car people just air you know laying you
their car took a couple in the early
days of the tour early days keep it
moving tour they keep it moving toward
the early days of ayg I didn't pull it
in the dash door yeah we did find a
shell casing in the car I couldn't in a
Russian Nissan we none of us had credit
cards to rent a car I had I've had to
put it on my debit card but a lot of
places won't rent you a credit card yeah
or rent you a car without a debit card
yeah at that time especially when you're
returning in a different city none of us
had we had zero dollars and none of us
had a had a credit card yeah that sound
that all checks out yeah you didn't have
one either did you still low yeah we
landed in I remember do you have a
credit card oh I was thinking license
yeah I remember being in Chicago walking
in to rent a car and then having to turn
around and walk out and be like well
what the [__] are we gonna do now dude I
was like start on my care or something I
remember you had a credit card for like
400 bucks and I was gonna have to like
we're gonna have to like overpay your
bill
yeah free up enough credit so we could
rent the car for like 500 bucks or
whatever what's going I know why they
call it hurts
Capital One started me out with 500
that's what they gave me yeah and they
turned their back on me that's all I can
do
um so now I got three G's and in there
that ain't bad it's all right but most
adults you know their credit limits like
20 grand you know mine right yeah but
but what you had that attached to the
business you flubbed that a little you
told him you're a baseball player I may
or may not have lied about my annual
income pre-tax negotiations
uh yeah but they Juiced me I also I
linked to I signed with Delta so I think
they were giving it away they got they
got their hooks at me I can't even look
at another airline [__] [__] shut
me down
put me on a no-fly list if I even think
about buying a [__] United ticket ah
man
you get you get real uh
you get real tight with your carrier I
look at like American United I'm like
yeah well I mean they know how to keep
you because now uh uh you know I'm high
up there ranked I come up and get things
personally on every flight we want to
thank you for flying with us Mr Ryan
look at you in a little hand handwritten
note from from the flight attendant
makes you feel warm and cozy ain't doing
that on Spirit [__] the Bell Rings
the next thing you know you're in a
three-round fight that's the only thing
they do I want to clean fight you're
like what the [__] all right you're in
an exit row and do you have hands you're
about to catch them it was a fight
breaks up can you handle yourself
instead of instead of are you willing
and able to help Hey listen [__] goes
down can I count on you stand the
handing out to Sandy wipes you're just
going around handing out weapons the
Wi-Fi's out and the dude and three bees
trying to catch a fade yeah the Wi-Fi on
the airplane is garbage sure that's a
scam well it doesn't really let you load
you can text and check emails but it
doesn't really let you load where's the
zero link or whatever elon's working on
a drop yeah but they'll probably [__]
block that so you can't pay so you can't
use that and you have to buy there they
want that cash that much the 10 bucks
they gotta squeeze you think about how
many people buy that a day think about
how many flights there are
it's a lot of [__] cash at the end of
the year that air travel is getting real
suspect too a lot of turbulence a lot of
[__] cancellations a lot of jam UPS I
just watched the British Airways flight
that had the okay landing and take off
that happens a lot I feel though is it a
win yeah yeah oh [__] in my pants sure
that's just one of those things if it's
happening you just gotta go hey [__]
I trust you baby just keep watching
catch me if you can keep that Wi-Fi
going I'll be all right
so I'm trying to get out of the city I
ain't got no [__] Wheels I can't rent
a car I gotta see the piece I ain't
going to [__] JFK to get a car then
fighting all the way back across the
city get the Philadelphia see my ma they
got plenty out there though
um so
we uh a friend in a building let us
borrow their car which I
am amazing guy was like borrow the car
anytime you want I know you're jammed up
that's not me I don't like doing that
because I don't like favors I'd rather
close his car I'd rather spend 70 grand
for for a zip car it's like sharing a
condom that is what
are you and your buddies doing Jesus
Christ
um yeah it's just it's not a great
feeling it's very let me say it's
unfamiliar very I mean that's a not a
kid as a teenager if you're driving
anybody's car hey Bill's too drunk
you're dry whatever you know what I mean
you the only you it would have to be
Paul verzie level cleanliness in the car
like it almost looked new for it to not
feel weird because it's always there's a
little TR there's this there's that
there's a smell I gotta be honest
fantastic very clean car what kind of
whip Lexus not bad all right yeah but
now you're in this guy's pocket
SUV nice ride plus now you got the hot
car now I got the house
yeah oh wife swapping okay I'm in with
the cars
um
me and T-Bone are thinking dirty things
switching wives condoms what are you two
doing when I'm away
[Laughter]
um so
now I just also always that you're just
ah
it just makes things icky of like what
if something happens how far are you
going toes because now I'm driving down
there the bridge alone's 16 bucks he's
got the easy pass away we don't know so
I text him I'm like coming up like I
don't see it but then I you know he
ended up he's like I got the easy pace
you're good
so buddy you rack up it's like 40 bucks
up and back oh yeah you give them that I
know but then he doesn't want to take it
at the you know what I mean no so I yes
I know no but he's going no I'm not
taking so hold on so we [__] so
there's that it's just messy it's just
messy thanks for the ride you're one of
the nine counties hey stay out of Jersey
will ya
don't look in the wheel well for a
couple of months
um
so
that deer's blood was already on the car
when I dug it
her headlights were missing right
this thing didn't have a catalog adults
though not crazy people like us but
adults know that one as you're allowed
to have somebody drive your car on like
a you know one or two time basis it's
still covered if anything happens God
forbid Insurance take care takes care of
it yeah of course but it's still like
I'm not dude it's pouring rain dude it's
poor it's a mon [__] soon what'd it
smell like in there I don't know a car
yeah yeah fine good the car was perfect
very clean he even did the pro thing of
uh it was very nice he even made a joke
about it we were like hey uh uh we set
it up and then he's like all right I'm
actually parked right out front on me
out front in five minutes so we go down
and he's got it already he's in it
because it's raining these people I
guess he would have he's revving the
engine you like what you see uh
and he just opened the door we hopped in
it was like an easy and he's like hey
the registration's right here in case
you need it I was like oh I've never
told anybody that when I've limped on my
car yeah and no one's usually I have to
give instructions like hey don't put it
in bark or [__] you know she shakes
at 45 when you're making a left-hand
turn careful there's no serial number on
that gun hey those beer bottles aren't
mine whatever you do don't open the
glove box yeah so that's I've I've never
I also I don't think I've ever borrowed
someone's car it's Man without
instructions of like
be careful this happens if it starts
beeping it's okay it pulls to the right
yeah like something like that he was
just like yeah it's yours I'm like what
the [__] you've had a jam up of jam ups
for the last for the last little while
but that really Takes the Cake yeah but
it's also like it's like seeing Superman
in his underwear you're borrowing your
neighbor's car he's a friend uh we're
we're very tight why don't you call me
by the way you live too far away I would
have drove it over there and then what I
would I would have drove you down there
he hadn't complained the next day the
whole time I [__] drive hippie down
to see his mom no yeah cause you won't
do a favor and not throw it in someone's
face would we have done a nice lunch no
I don't want to hang out with you and my
mom the two [__] people who nag me
the most you gotta be way down the car
like a limo driver
bring me on a cup of coffee you two give
me more headaches I swear it's like
hanging out with your wife and your
girlfriend who wants to do that you know
what I mean sure do not Cowboys talk
about Trade coffee Trade coffee that old
coffee in the break room just isn't
hitting it for you anymore is it gang
nope you gotta do yourself a favor get
the good stuff and we're talking about
Trade coffee trade connects people to
the best coffee roasters in the country
and chips freshly right to your door
yeah it's basically like a coffee dating
app you find out what you want they got
over 450 coffee options trades delicious
algorithm make sure you and your true
love finds each other baby and add some
dark roast coffee for campy boy love it
let me tell you David they're shipping
it here every two days I'm getting in
them hoodies hiding the beans I gotta go
looking for them I like keeping it open
it's like an air freshener I love the
smell of fresh nice little Aroma cooking
we got it uh short guy Vinny's making
cold brew with it he is uh with free
shipping customizable plans and anytime
cancellation it's easier than ever to
discover incredible coffee uh if you
don't think that can get any better your
coffee is always shipped within 48 Hours
of being roasted look at that that's
Farm to Table type stuff you guys burn
your fingers on that by the time it gets
here big caution still hot maybe get
ready for the best coffee of your life
with trade go to drinktrade.com
ayg to receive a free bag of coffee with
any subscription look at that look at
that uh that's a free bag of coffee with
any trade subscription at drinktrade.com
ayg or by clicking the link in the show
notes your next cup of coffee is on the
boys there you go do it we go we'll be
bringing it back and there's like a lit
I don't want to say there was an issue
but there wasn't an issue but I did I
was going pretty fast and I heard like a
little you hear that what's that type
thing and I didn't do anything but it's
like is it all me is it not on me what
was the noise I I can't even I I
couldn't even like pinpoint it it wasn't
constant it just like popped up at one
point it was mostly smoke really
abort abort abort
you're driving in first gear I just
[__]
the RPMs are supposed to be in red right
so no it was fine
um and we so now we park it
but like we gotta you know here you are
with that yes well it's like no one
parks on that I mean they're called
bustling did you leave it they're taking
cars on that block on the on the Block
that we got taken from left and right
stealing oh dude or just taking all the
tires you show up that's all milk crates
no kidding dude it's like [__]
downtown Beirut look at that you got
four milk crates though hey good for you
pal uh
this is always a silver lining I guess
huh you gotta use those what the [__]
going on up there bro
Wallace man where's the popo what's
going on I don't know man I don't know I
don't work for the city what do I know
the city the city's falling apart
keep your baby in that garage I'll tell
you that sure for sure because they'll
be looking for that oh yeah yeah with my
spinning rims I got on it a couple of
times the [__] Lambo doors I throw on
this thing
you get into the hood uh
so now but there's until we park it in a
uh so then so we gotta we give them the
keys back and he wrote I was like hey
man here's 40 bucks for tolls and he's
like that's too much I'm not taking it
I'm like why but because he's a nice guy
you know I would do the you know you
know whatever whatever but it's just
like that him and Hauling of like I
don't I'm like dude why would you pay
for my tolls after you let me borrow
your car I did return with a full tank
of gas that's what I was gonna ask you
and that's three quarters that's the
really well this is what happened
see you're gonna yell you're gonna get
mad at me and say oh you just always
like to do this you wouldn't do this I
have a
line problem no
um
yeah but
there's a certain way I would have
handled the return of this and I want to
hear how you did it you're already
losing points the 40 bucks cash
again what's the 40 bucks cash how else
am I supposed to pay him back
I'll tell you if you tell me hey wait no
we'll go to the gas how am I supposed to
pay them back the the 40 bucks that's
built his easy pass this is what you do
in that moment
you know so I'll take care of the I'll
take care of the other tools no I don't
worry about it dang dude that's so cool
here whatever here's the key the next
day or that week all right you do
a bottle of wine you do something you
come back with a full tank first of all
maybe getting it washed but it was
raining I'll give you that you've never
done any of this see I knew this is what
he's gonna do what do I know I know how
you operate I know later on you go back
would he ever wash someone's car and
give it back to him yeah I would I've
done that before when I've borrowed
somebody's car can I be honest with you
yes I'm having fun living in the fantasy
let's see where this goes sure I'd be
the nicest guy in the world and do
everything bottle of wine your trash a
card with with with uh
if you had said I would have dictated
these things to be done to my girl and
had her execute them no I would take
care of that okay I'll live in this
fantasy with you okay a bottle of wine
and a gift certificate to a nice
restaurant up there for a hundred bucks
plus the co plus the tanks coming back
all right that's a jug of Carlo Rossi in
a Burger King gift card yeah okay sure
that would be nice sure
you got a [__] problem with Burger
King now
success I think for my wedding you gave
me a 15 Target gift card I wasn't
invited but you're giving this guy 14
dinners I showed up I showed up with a
bunch of stuff
now he's each got a couple of gift cards
she got she got they were half used
shoes
she got some roshes
for the bozos and the homies I'm telling
you what I would do okay and I'm telling
you as I know you quite well I don't and
we've this is where we bump heads of
things you say you [__] on me for doing
things and in theory you would do the
greatest thing in the world and I've
never seen you do any of it is that a
fair assessment no I do stuff like that
all the time I never show up to a place
empty-handed I always show what a nice
bottle that's not feeling a tank of gas
washing a car give them a bottle of wine
and a hundred dollar gift card to dinner
that's what I would do okay all right if
anything just to look cool sure the flex
sure
um so three quarters of a tank well this
is what happened I got it on e Property
he goes it's on a but you can take it
Jesus yeah so I immediately filled it a
faux Pond his Park well it's I mean it's
pouring rain we asked to borrow his car
if that's not enough oh is it like a
last minute thing yeah it was like
actually yeah we will can we borrow the
car how did that come up how did he
become aware of that I think he offered
but she was the bird was probably
telling his wife they're in a group chat
with the she's in a group chat with them
yeah yeah she wants to go see his mom
but he doesn't have a car he's a loser
oh yeah no [__] this guy
so uh coffee shop I think we could do a
little bit of better than that
fogman
Seinfeld does everybody knows
um
so yeah that was last minute it was very
last minute because I couldn't get a car
because I was like now we'll just rent a
car and then I couldn't get my hands on
a car nothing's really working out for
you
this time would eat you up and he gives
you cash as you're leaving puts it in my
pocket hey good kid let me take her out
to let me take her out for a nice
meeting take your mom out for a cup of
coffee
um no so it was very last minute he goes
yeah it's on it you can take it but it's
on E like proper honey and I you can't
fault the guy for [__] no no no not
at all I didn't know that was the case
yeah no it wasn't like ham bar in your
car next Tuesday I would have guessed it
up though if you were borrowing mine of
course you would have because you're the
nicest
I would have done it nice for you
pretty clean anyway
okay sure I just offered Tommy to take
the car what he was already gone the
Tommy Cassidy okay he was going down to
Philly so he could have should have took
mine sure I don't really want to give it
to him I know I mean
we live in this world I'll let you I'm
the only honest one on the gosh darn
show hey and Toby
you just have a car you're a cheapskate
though I'm not a cheapskate so why'd you
bring it back on three quarters because
we filled it up completely I mean I put
like I don't know what [__] was
what's it take to fill an SUV on a
[__] Jersey Turnpike 60 fifth seventy
I think it was more than that it was
like 90. okay
um so I'm 90 in and then it was just
under it was just over three quarters of
a tank
so you got down there and back on a
quarter tank of gas yeah hmm pretty bad
an hour up and back sure I guess it's
got good highway I wasn't driving too
fast
it's a proper hour like an hour and ten
or something like that yeah you're
[__] lucky yeah yeah it's not too far
it ain't too shabby but then the thing
is we had to park it and we parked it
in uh Denise is charging for parking
is it tough down there no when we get
back to the city we got to look for
parking yeah and now we're coming back
into Sunday you're looking for Park it's
a whole thing uh and I felt kind of bad
but it was also like
I just left it running it's on 98th
Street on the east side you familiar
with Hoboken
thank the ferry it's nice
he's my metro card if you want Bozo why
why am I a bozo you just are why it's
now yeah do you want me to go over the
list yeah paint me in this thing and you
paint yourself in another light which
I'll give you for the sense of Comedy
but when a rubber hits the road I know
you all right now I'm very good with
that stuff with Lion sure yeah the
rights yeah but you say that but yeah
that insinuates that I don't care you're
like I care which which means I don't
care when I can you didn't force the 40
on I mean I did give him the 40 you
[__] idiot I said that are you gonna
get there he got the I overpaid the
tolls the tolls are probably 31 he got
nine dollars out of me there you get
changed he got nine he got 850 out of me
on it he got a five on you
can you break this hey buddy can you
break a five is there a Coinstar around
here
I had a day of dad talking to change out
of the cup holder
here's a nice pair of gloves too it's
also it's all it's all pennies left in
there I took all the silver
I got you an ice scraper from the back
seat there you go
uh
give him his tire iron
that thing was on a donut when he gave
it to me
um
it's gonna be funny you take the card
and immediately chop it up
I don't know what happened his premium
stayed on us right uh no so luckily we
had to pay so we had we put it in a
Monday morning spot that had to be moved
by much so we park it Sunday afternoon
it's got to be moved Monday and this is
probably I know but but then he feels
like you feel bad and I'm like me and my
wife like should we move it and we're
like hey he had already taken the keys
and we're like hey we'll move it for you
uh but luckily he's like no I'm he's
like it was in a Monday spot when I gave
it to you oh he was gonna have to move
it anyway okay but this does raise all
those things of that I hate that get
like you don't want anybody to feel
unhole or that like I don't like people
thinking I'm like that's why you gotta
make it above and beyond
sure I mean I gave him 75 worth of gas
and more money than the tolls were yeah
so you basically fill this tank up yeah
he gave it to me on it like proper gas
light on I was like we cross the bridge
I'm like [__] I have to get a [__] so
we got a free tank again
no sweat off him wasn't using it that
day and 850. that's 98.50 he's making
money sitting on the couch 97 bucks I'll
snip some Gippy farts I don't think I
farted did you eat in there
you're not gonna like this
[Laughter]
I can joke her up my sleeve
spaghetti
what'd you do while we were coming down
Route One there and I had to stop to
take a tanky that's just on the way back
here on the way there on the way there
we didn't you have plans to go to lunch
or anything like that with your mom sure
okay A little appetizer will kill you
hey
um who got you Tony Luke's Tony Luke's
yeah Tony Luke's on Route One there no
the golden arches I had to stop to take
a pee
so the only thing the gas stations are
in the middle of New Jersey
that's like connected to a Dunkin Donuts
looks like a [__] bomb of poop went
off it's not great diarrhea grenade
they're [__] real bad dude and the
guy looks at you we're real weird on the
way in now Jersey cream donut in there
it ain't good so what time of the day is
this
noonish one-ish something like that
early afternoon perfect time for a
Mickey D stub but I was anti I said I
don't want to eat fast food in this car
it's you don't do that no you can't uh
[Applause]
give me a 20 piece
Papa those things like Tic Tacs
uh we did get a large order of fries the
bird wanted fries I pushed against it
that's it just fries really man I would
never do I could never do that I'm well
aware maybe now only those empties you
could I wouldn't do it
sure yeah I don't know I mean she was
just more like I haven't had McDonald's
fries in probably three years ago you
know what I don't you know how were they
they were really good yeah you gotta got
good and fresh but can I ask you this
just a little side note let's say you
guys are driving maybe in your own car
uh if I ever again maybe some some
acquaintance or you steal a car uh
you're driving in your car you're going
somewhere and you do stop
let's say you stop and get fast food or
you stop and get something on the road
like a sandwich and you know [__] like
that
does she shotgun it for you
like you're driving will she like
unwrapped it give me half the sandwich
yeah yeah I love that it's like everyone
if you feel like a dentist
Mr Slurpee please yeah dude yeah
spreader Big Mac
sandwich
I said sandwich give me my Coke now
please
hand it to me right
um yeah so we I was anti but she pushed
for it and are you dipping him in
anything she gets some catching she did
catchy I'm not doing uh uh I'm not
dipping in someone else's car while
driving in a rain that ain't happening
did you check
thoroughly for any loose french fries
because those McDonald's fries have a
way of Disappearing a couple of them
like to wander off man I remember
looking under my mom my I was looking
for a lighter in my mom's Sebring
convertible back in high school when I
was 16. I was looking under the seat man
there must have been like three [__]
small fries under there you could have
filled it was just fries the craziness
they look like they just came out of the
fries they hold they really the hardest
diamonds yeah still got flavor though
got glass with those [__] let me ask
you this
how many cars in America right now have
at least one french fry in it 98 you
think so I would say 60 because you
gotta account for rental cars vegans
that kind of thing they're not stop you
know
french fries are vegan yeah but I mean
no one's just you know you go there for
a burger and a chicken man you ever see
like a parent's car nowadays
like a [__] Toyota Sienna with the
two kid seats in the back sure
stinks smells like old milk and yeah
gold ranted [__]
um yeah so McDonald's fries aren't vegan
they contain natural beef flavoring yeah
probably Tallow or whatever you know I
hear that stuff's good for your face the
bird doesn't she does all over it smells
like I'm [__] making love to gravy
wait
turn you on a little bit huh babe I love
Thanksgiving does it really smell like
beef
yeah it's like beef gel ugh if I can't
scent that I don't know the dog loves it
man she puts that on get out of here
guys my wife he starts howling at the
moon she puts it on before she goes to
bed all right now I don't know I don't
know the exact face facial routine has
she said she sees any improvement from
it I think she claims she does yeah
because I don't want to get she moves a
lot I don't want nothing
what are we doing here I don't want to
get too gross but one of the things but
I'll be me yeah one of the things that
I'm it's really starting to happen with
me as a covering yourself with bacon
grease no I'm getting older I have like
like not even moles like you saw that
thing on my leg that like it's like
little elephant skin I've had them all
checked every I go to the dermatologist
all the time but skin tags and like
these they're not mold they're like um
I don't know what the [__] they're
called like just these little like weird
things that it's really [__] gross
man I'm getting like old person's skin
you're an older gentleman I'm not a
young spry guy like me and Tebow and I
do when I just went to the uh
dermatologist to get this uh mole taken
off
um I showed him the things in my back I
have like like they're like crocodile
scales in my back and I'm like there's
got to be like he's like you can scrape
them off but it'd be real painful and
it's not really worth anything it's just
you're just getting older and I'm like
yeah I don't want that you've got
Barnacles dude there's gotta be I'll
show you it's [__] an Old Ship I
thought it was because I wasn't
scrubbing good enough back there but
he's like nah scrubbing's not going to
take it away there's no cream that can
take it away boom Dino DNA there's gotta
be
some type of diet or something that can
clear that can clear your skin really
good and a lot of people have been
talking about Tallow sure yeah yeah I
don't know all that stuff some of the
birds face products that I use are
really good but you got to really stay
on top of that yeah
I don't like that it smells like beef
though
I mean it's beef biting my arm
s
piece of bread if I could mop it up a
little bit oh olive oil over here
Family episode we gotta get it yes we do
let's do some cues gang as you know when
you sign up for the old patreon you can
have a question right on the air
nothing to [__] around baby this
one's from Mr Neptune 2022. a little
competition in the building is it
garbage to have a one year anniversary
twice with the same person after being
broken up for a while
I don't know if that's one you can
celebrate right I don't get it you have
you you date somebody for 18 months you
have your one year anniversary you break
up for two years you get back together
you have another one year anniversary
sure I don't think that scene that
doesn't feel right in my natural and
yeah as it as it runs through the
processor real quick two one-year
anniversaries with the same guy or gal
do you I mean I would just say
anniversary
um yeah but you know there's an app yeah
so we got two different days sure
there's a there's an asterisk on that oh
well you're telling me they celebrate
both of them I don't know they've
celebrated two one-year anniversaries on
two different days at some point in your
life that seems a little
that's got chilies written all over it
which I don't mind but not at all
um I think for that one you just start
at the next period this is our second
anniversary our third you get past the
the muddled phase there right yeah
I've never been a big anniversary guy
I forget a bunch
I should know it's a scam man mine's
always right next to my out of my
wedding anniversary is right next to
wedding anniversary yeah but that's
right uh uh thanks or uh Thanksgiving uh
I've got a beef Delo want to bring
that's right next to uh Valentine's Day
there you go so I just did we just lump
that all in together there you go I like
Geico I give her give her three quarters
a thing called a day
try to give it Easy Pass money she
wouldn't dig it
um all right let's see here this one's
from I like Valentine's Day just the
candy wise Homer we've talked to you
you're just like the candy love the
candy yeah love a heart-shaped Dove
chocolate
uh this one's from the furo flatbread
are you garbage if your grandmother
freezes milk instead of going to the
store to buy it each week that's crazy
this has come up on the show before it's
absolutely insane but I know
a lot of when I was growing up a lot of
people that had a bunch of kids did it
all the time it's a very Grandmom 80s
thing to do T-Bone can you get a can you
get a shelf life on frozen milk so I'm
doing a little investigative reporting
now it's fine because it's Gotta taste a
little bit different it's got I mean an
egg a waffle in there too long gets
[__] some bite on it yeah I recently
had to look up can you freeze cream
cheese
um and the answer is you can but no
Alaska what are you doing it'll be a
little Sandy this real scientist over
there huh yeah well we were trying to
get some Cricket popsicles trying to get
some bagels and cream cheese over to
Hawaii gotcha yeah there's got to be a
company that does that yeah but they
want like the you know the real New York
ones I'm sure got a cartel submarine
full of Philadelphia it's called poppy
seeds Coast Guard banging on the door
six months you can keep frozen milk for
there you go so I gotta taste different
it has to I would assume you would know
I feel like if you made me a bottle uh a
bowl of [__] Cocoa Pebbles with that
and a bowl of Cocoa Pebbles with a
regular [__] that weak milk
I'll know I'll have to be able to tell
there's nothing I I just you can't be
chemically physically changed in the
form of something and then it it doesn't
bounce back yeah
yeah
I would agree
um
but I respected spaghetti sauce is okay
that comes out fine sometimes it's even
better yes but it's changed soup is
better when you're free but it all
changes
it doesn't affect the taste but it does
affect the texture gross here we go of
milk yes nope you're not changing listen
I love milk I love milk but you're right
there on the line with the texture
anyway this is crazy this is saying that
the best way to freeze milk is to put it
into an ice cube tray then put that into
the Frozen cubes into a Ziploc bag and
then store it that way she's
imagine rolling over your buddy's house
for a sleepover and you go to get like
breakfast or something in the morning
and they they bust out frozen milk hold
on
I would call it it's not gonna work in a
milkshake I've already been thinking
about it no the way to get the coldest
glass of milk make milk cubes get a
glass of milk and put the milk cubes in
there
oh God you got the you got the big one I
think it's scotch
got a shaving Orange in there shaping it
up oh that'd be nice A little Citrus
Twist on it yeah maybe that would be
good like a [__] creamsicle okay I
could see it I could see it in a White
Russian
I'll give you that I'll give you that
I'll give it it's fun
that's really taken to the next level
yeah a little non-dairy creamer in there
a milk cube
man I can't but that's that's actually
pretty smart it's pretty good that'd be
delicious between that and the chopped
cheese omelette I'm really doing some
stuff over here doing all right shout
out to the chopped cheese omelette kids
working hard over there uh all right
this one's from Foxy Cleopatra is a
garbage just sit and eat corn on the cob
at your desk job
yeah that's no [__] good that's not a
that's a barbecue only
time food I have to disagree I don't
think it's that track it's not like
bringing a piece of fish in the office
and I'm sure that that was left over
from the barbecue the night before in
the summer in an area where corn is very
prevalent which Pennsylvania it is
you're making a lot of assumptions this
could be in [__] Boston Massachusetts
for all you know you don't know your
fresh corn I'm sure they have corn farms
in Boston you know what I'm saying this
is because when I was home last
um we did corn on the cob and I didn't
have any then but the next day I just
had two cold ears out of the fridge yeah
yeah that's fine I'm not dude it's it
was so good I'm not saying it ain't good
and you can't fully grown corn but at
your work at a desk job that's the
Butter's getting all over the keyboard
the phone jamming up the stapler get the
two things yeah that's what I'm saying
come on you can't be known it's
something at work that's a different
it'd be a gentleman shave it off if you
want which is psychopath Behavior to me
to begin with I think in those office
gigs once you get in there and you get
settled
you're no one's really standing on airs
and I respect that you know I don't know
there is a protocol people obviously
step over the line but there is that's
that's weird to me I would never [__]
I think fish and anything smelly is
where the line is
I mean that's offensive horn fish oh yes
that's what I'm saying
you've got to look at me while I'm
eating my corns they keep your [__]
eyes in your cubicle uh cause I doubt
he's walking around the office is doing
a plane
eating corn on the cob on a plate I
would argue it's the same thing you're
around other strangers you need there's
a courtesy no no that's different I
assume this person has their own cubicle
you know you're assuming the best case
scenario what do they work at picnic
tables I don't know a lot of cubicles
you share with like four people like you
each have a corner
I mean when I was in a cubicle there was
three other people and if someone was
eating a [__] if somebody if there
was a guy next to me eating corn on the
cob I would have for sure taken a
picture of him and texted you and we
would have made fun of him but if it was
the summer and it was like after Fourth
of July you eat that [__] at home you
have that for dinner when you get home
or breakfast with your ice cube milk
whatever you want to do keep it the [__]
out of the office that's what I say Ice
Cube milk and sandwiches that's not a
good way to start the day that's farmer
breakfast right there fall asleep on the
drive to work there's for sure someone
listening to this who paused this to go
put milk in their ice cream sure enough
totally if you have hit us up let us
know the results uh yeah I don't know I
mean it's not trash it's not it's one of
those things it's weird to me it just
immediately rubs me the wrong way like
kissing your cousin sure you know what I
mean I could see someone doing that on a
mega bus and not really batting an eye
out same thing I mean come on well then
now you're lower in the standard of it's
okay to do it on you're assuming people
are gonna do it on a mega bus so it is
has some sort of connotation to it
people eat their feet on a Mega Bus man
you ain't lying I saw a guy take his
shirt off one time
VIP
has gone to Boston
man so Buddy's just chilling dude
getting real comfy Lumpy
the Mega Bus stays next
uh I was always scared anything could
pop off
our Megabus days we took them a lot took
a lot of lots of Atlantic City a lot to
Philly a lot to uh anytime I went to
Boston a handful of times I took them
they were your the drivers weren't
[__] nuts they're doing like 90
they're bobbing and weaving
the people on them are [__] crazy
it's like people getting out of town
they just murdered somebody they're
[__] trying flying under the radar
I drank a lot of wine out of Gatorade
bottles yeah it's a lot of it's a lot of
pre there's a lot of drunk Toby's yeah
free sober Toby it's not a guy you want
to be take your shirt off for a second
let me see
both are you
were you going from here to yeah
um all right let's see here this one's
from Cameron first time long time shout
out to you there's a garbage you use
crackers for nachos if you don't have
any tortilla chips
I don't hate it because I'm he said they
would use Ritz a lot okay which is a
great cracker yes the foleys
um it depends what we're talking about
the foleys were always big on when my
mom made chili there was no shredded
cheese it was sour cream you get a
little dollop of sour cream and a bunch
as many crackers as you want
crab the Crispies the the
saltines and you could use Ritz too so I
could see that
yeah I had a couple of Ritz not that
long ago [__] blow your [__] hair
back buttery yeah they're great they're
great that like a screaming cold Coke
from a garage fridge didn't appreciate
them when we were kids really I did I
really got some peanut butter on it for
the Plano dude I really at a young age
appreciated assaulting whatever the
townhouse Toll House toll house
and the [__] uh the club I like the
club it was all right they were a little
not my cup of tea but and the [__]
Ritz I loved I would just mulch a
[__] sleeve of crackers mulch them
spray cheese on there I was about to say
for the Ritz nacho I feel like the spray
cheese would be the way to go that's not
bad wait run into trouble would be like
the beans and the guac
he had alluded to this being a very high
food so it's like I don't know if
they're doing the beans and the guac I'm
assuming it's salsa cheese you know okay
some hot sauce or something yeah I could
throw it on crackers my cousin used to
uh all Domino's dude what are you doing
she got me on it for a little bit when I
was a kid was a Ritz cracker with uh
cream cheese and a little ketchup
okay that's I mean in my in my fat kid
making food days that was never I wasn't
getting any of that stuff out if I did
it now I would use cocktail sauce I
remember for a long time making [__]
a bowl of [__] cheese whiz throw that
in the microwave and then just have
[__] those Townhouse crackers or
whatever and just [__] oh man burn in
my mouth quickly chasing it with a cold
Coke just [__] stand and not even
taking it into the [__] into the TV
like in the living room to watch TV
standing at the counter just [__]
munching it you know speaking of that
that's another thing the Olympics is
taken away the bite she's with the bite
and sip really yeah somebody was calling
me crazy in a comment or a tag or
something they were like isn't it nuts
that Kevin is a biting sip guy oh the
bite and sip all [__] day that's the
way to go you're nuts if you're doing it
if you're doing it any other way yeah
soft pretzel oh that's what it's all
about that's what America is dude yeah
that's why our forefathers fall for this
country so I could [__] bite I'll be
turned off buy a meal if I have to have
water with it oh yeah I'm just starting
to get into that and you see me when we
go out somewhere if I don't have I need
a fresh Diet Coke you start getting real
nervous I get real just never coming
back the walls are closing in on me you
go through that first one like a
nine-year-old I have it time so here's
my thing they dry hey we go to a diner
on the road or whatever I get it I gotta
I get a Diet Coke drop I [__] I do
about 75 percent of that like a like a
tank of gas [__] hit that
um
then I know they're coming back to
either drop the food or check in or drop
something I go can I get another Diet
Coke right is it maybe they drop the
food so hopefully he comes right back
drops it and I got my full meal and a
full so you have some bite and sip
capability to start off and hopefully I
get you know the the air support comes
in yeah
I don't like when they refill the glass
they never put the ice back in they're
like handy your straw you're like what
are we doing here [__] just give me a
new glass are you that jammed up back
there there's four people in this
[__] restaurant
what are you eating
I'm speaking of a diner in my
neighborhood they give you the cans kind
of warm I hate that which I don't mind
okay you control your own destiny you
know what I mean bars do that a lot
they'll give you the first one is a
[__] screaming cold glass from the
fridge and then the next one it's like
it's got the still got dish soap on it
kills you a couple of Suds in there
kills you uh
uh speaking of that this is from Tom
Rogers ten dollar homie here I recently
went to a bar back in my hometown Akeem
New Hampshire shout out to you where I
learned this place serves air fried
dinosaur chicken nuggies at the bar
that's wonderful
I love that as you know I'm a big tender
nuggy kind of guy as a kid with all that
stuff the french fries that were in the
oven the chicken patties the chicken
nuggets chicken patty really fell off or
just disappeared I would say that was a
weaver chicken patty oh my God that was
chicken burgers that was a staple in our
house yeah delicious I don't make them
that much Mickey D's old school chicken
sandwich no but I'm saying for consumers
not at a restaurant or a place I'm sure
you have they're just not that popular I
don't know why that's what I said yeah
they I mean they were [__] a chicken
patty was everywhere unbelievable I
haven't [__] I ain't never been to no
one's house and they break out their CPS
on me unbelievable
um but I used to always think to myself
man if I just had a fryer this would be
so much better I never thought of that
once in my life because we did have the
fried daddy growing up which I've said
before shout out to the friend you never
you don't know the fried Daddy I do it's
so dangerous
yeah I did leave the lid on and it
plugged in one time and the lid melted
into the good flavor and into the
[__] Crisco
we also had one with a basket we're
[__] that's what I oh man it was
great I remember me and my brother tried
to fry chicken one time and we didn't
batter it I think we just threw in like
frozen chicken man made a pipe pump yeah
dude it was it was all hands on deck for
a couple of minutes there yeah it was
I think we came home we were I remember
we were working overnights
[__] doing construction working
overnights and we were like we got home
in the morning
fell asleep woke up and we had to be at
work in like an hour so we're like What
can we make there's no food in the house
mom's working down the shore whatever
like you know those summer days were
there sometimes there was nothing it's
like the parents get older yeah ain't no
food in the house and we were like
trying to make something work and I
remember literally the place when was
going up [__] frozen food in a
[__] I used to love making something
work it's all right
it ain't bad baby
um uh all right let's see here this is
from Jake
um do you put your hand on the wall over
the urinal when you're taking a leak I
do it at my house I lean on the wall
like this in my apartment yeah a public
I ain't touching nothing in a public
bathroom I don't even wash my hands nah
I don't wash my hands either I don't
touch anything in a public pool I'll hit
the Purell on the way out if it's if
it's there yeah even then I'll wait to
the one that's like hopefully I see
outside the bathroom catch one in the
you know more common area I don't know
what that soap is
a nice bathroom at a nice restaurant
like a nice single bath it has a nice
paper towel usually a candle in there
I'll wash my hands there that's a treat
that's the fanciest place I ever been
yeah
but a rest stop or something like that a
bar I'm not doing it and I don't like to
but at home I do really [__] you do I
do rest up yeah
man I think it's something I've recently
started doing I never remember doing it
I think it like in my head at like
you're like stretched so there's no like
no there's no kinks in a hose you know
they're on top of that thing yeah I
don't I I don't know if it I've gotten
into a bad habit over the last few years
of standing real far away
I can tell by the tinkies all over the
bathroom yeah hoodies I don't know why
you gotta you gotta get up on that or
start sitting down or something all
right I got those empties a couple more
months I'll be all right okay but get up
on it fall in that thing
and we see Foley
uh all right let's see let's do two more
here and then we got a Rizzle uh this is
a big one for fat guys and you know
skinny guys alike this from Jeffrey uh
never had one red is a garbage and make
your own holes in a belt which we were
just recently talking about I just had
to do that yeah because it's too tight
or too high because it was it wasn't it
wasn't tight enough you're a skinny mini
good for you I had I yeah as a fat guy
I've gone up of course of course and
dude it's always when it ain't that easy
no it is very hard and it's always the
last thing you think of I'm like getting
ready to go to a wedding or something
and it's like that nice dress belt that
I haven't touched in [__] three years
because a knife doesn't do it well yeah
do you like
yo you never really gauge it right
either it's never and trying to find
that thing when you can't see it holy
[__] yeah
shout out to the leather workers of
America because I didn't know it was
that hard you think you just ping pow
poke it in poke it out it well once once
you wear it a few times it really opens
up on you oh yeah yeah yeah yeah I've
had to do it and it's always that panic
I have like I'm like have my pants on
like I'm like getting ready to go like a
communion or something like my fancy
clothes or whatever and just like I have
like a pocket knife or something just
[__] trying to cut through and you
know it's [__] I remember going to a
wedding a few years ago I and I have
this [__] mad at myself still eight
though didn't you fatty I know dude just
being like you [__] fat piece of [__]
you're always waiting to the last minute
oh shrimp cocktail and it's also I never
knew how to buy a belt so I would go
like oh okay this looks all right they
don't make no sense I think it's your I
think I used to know because I used to
when I worked at Macy's they had to tell
me I think it's your waist plus two well
thank you 38 waist you go to a 40 or 42.
okay
um yep yeah it is two inches greater 32
pants 34 belt I one time went to a
wedding and I hadn't worn the suit was
an old suit I hadn't worn it in like
maybe like a year or two and I put
weight on and didn't try it on or
nothing like that and it's hot I have
the shirt tucked in and I'm trying to
close the pants and I I just can't I
literally like at my I'm like starting
to feel like I'm having a heart attack
and I can't get them [__] clothes
yeah so I had to keep that open zip the
zipper up and tight tighten the belt I'm
gonna tucked the shirt and let the shirt
hang out over I've done that that is man
talk about leaving the house with
[__] anxiety
Stinger flopping out when you're doing
the Electric Slide or something
that poor zipper dude like Spider-Man in
front of the train he's doing the job of
three things he's doing the belt he's
got the Button Man all keeping your fat
ass intact I know that also the panic I
hate suits dude I'm getting ready to go
to like you know of some something that
I'm not capable of going to I'd go buy
[__] pants at PJ Maxx for 14.99 I'd
eyeball them they'd be huge or you know
whatever or too tight or trying to I
remember so many times trying to put
pants on and being like oh this isn't
that thing you're like you're not
getting there and I'm like all right I
would take them off and see what else I
had of like I looked at my brother or my
dad something like trying to find trying
to find a solution suit just became a
Believer with a pair of shorts
and that summer I'd go back to that pair
of pants being like let me try again and
like putting those things back on be
like dude it ain't [__] happening I
have BTSD of that's why I hate shopping
for clothes now hate it it's sweating in
a fight a fitting room with it not
buttoning you look like [__] my wife's
like why don't you like shopping I'm
like because they [__] it just
reminds me of a fat piece of [__] I've
been a fat piece of [__] my whole life
[__] traumatized that's why I'm
[__] in the Husky section and that
don't even fit yeah my mom's going how
fat are you in a hot Sears on a Thursday
night okay you know how embarrassed it
is the 34s don't fit you're like what
the [__] lady keep your voice down I'm
trying to get laid out Patty always
brought an audience in too yeah she had
like two three customer service reps
there too she's [__] Jammy up oh God
damn I'll have them
and I remember I got a pair of Lee pipes
I wanted Janko she wouldn't give me
jankos I got a pair of lead pipes and
then she hemmed them man you can barely
see the Stitch dude
[Music]
you know what I'm talking dressed up
like a doll
Chucky's pants dude
it was uh it was the the the the the the
the
hemline was so faint you know that's
chunky you did a [__] microscope to
see how to get real up on it to see it I
remember being so she goes what I had
them hand for you
man they were I was like a pair of
floods dude they were hanging they
didn't even touch my shoes
but they were real wide you know it
looked like I was wearing a dress boot
cut oh man it was bad we gotta wrap it
up Jesus ah man yeah Chucky's pants was
all right
junkie
Chuckie's cousin yeah
gang we love yous we love you to death
patreon thank you for the ten thousand
we love you we can't thank you enough we
love you come out and see us on the road
we're coming tons of places we're coming
everywhere there's low tickets in most
cities where we're not uh adding we're
not adding shows and all the all the
cities it just doesn't make sense we
just can't make it work with our
schedule so get your tickets don't
[__] snooze uh we'd love to see you
out there we love seeing everybody it's
the best guys thank you so much see you
next week peace